In the price to earnings
conundrum video we encountered
a situation where two different
entrepreneurs bought
an identical asset, in this case
it was a pizza parlor or
a pizzeria, but they
each financed it
in a different way.
This guy was a little bit
more conservative.
He paid for it outright.
The entire asset
was his equity.
He had no debt.
While this guy, he borrowed
some money and he even had
some non-operating assets.
So he levered up.
For every $1 he put in he
borrowed $10 from the bank in
order to buy more assets
that he actually
brought to the table.
And we saw when you did their
financial statements-- their
revenue, cost of goods--
everything up to the operating
profit line was the same.
And that makes sense because,
if you remember the first
introduction to income statement
video, operating
profit is really indicative of
what the operating assets are
generating.
So in this case it's what this
purple area right here is
generating.
You could also consider
that the enterprise.
What the enterprise
is generating.
And everything below the
operating line, everything
below the operating profit line,
is either coming from
non-operating assets, that
would the case of
non-operating income.
And the entrepreneur on the
right had some of that.
He had some of this
non-operating income, $2,000
per year in that case.
While this guy didn't
have any.
And then you have expenses
associated
with interest. Right?
In this case this entrepreneur
had 5% of
$100,000, so $5,000 a year.
And then when you have these
differences in capital
structure it changes what
your net income is.
And they have slightly different
net income numbers.
But what we saw is when we
applied the same price to
earnings ratio, and they had
the same share counts-- I
didn't change too many variables
here I just really
changed how they paid
for the asset.
But when you apply the same
price to earnings ratio to
both earning streams, to both
companies, you got something
that was reasonably
unintuitive.
And there's no trick
here really.
Because it's not crazy to
assign the same price to
earnings ratio.
And if you try it out, if you
grow this guy's revenue a
little bit, if you actually grow
both of their revenues by
the same amount or both of their
gross profits by the
same amount or if you grow
both of their operating
profits by the same amount,
you're actually going to see
that this guy's earnings per
share is growing faster.
So given that someone might
say, oh, because of the
leverage maybe I'm willing to
pay even a higher multiple.
So it's not crazy to pay the
same multiple for both of
these guys.
But we saw at the end of the
last video, when you apply,
let's say, a 10 multiple, or
really any multiple to both of
these earning streams, you get
a situation that at first
doesn't look crazy.
OK, the market cap of this guy
is $210,000 if you apply a 10
multiple to their earnings
stream, while the market cap
of this guy is $189,000 if you
apply a 10 multiple to their
earning stream.
Right?
10 times 18.9 thousand
is 189,000.
10 times 21 thousand
is 210,000.
But what was the conundrum, what
really got us thinking,
was how can this whole equity
stream right here, or this
equity, or this earnings stream
be, worth 210 and this
one be worth 189 when this guy
only put $10,000 in initially
and this guy put $100,000?
He put in 10 times as much.
And so when you're paying
$210,000 for this asset, for
this equity, you are essentially
saying that this
asset is worth $210,000.
But if you're saying that this
equity is worth $189,000,
right, that's what the
market cap is.
It's the value of the equity.
Then you're implicitly saying
that this asset, that all of
these assets are worth the
value of this market
capitalization plus
this debt, right?
So that's $289,000.
And then if you wanted the value
of this operating asset
you would subtract out this
much right here, the cash.
So you got something
like $279,000.
So when you apply the same price
to earnings to to these
similar businesses you've
actually got a situation where
you're overpaying for this asset
relative to this one,
even though they're identical.
So that left us with a question:
what do we do?
What can we use other than a
price to earnings ratio?
And that's what this
video is for.
So the short answer is,
one, you do have to
use something different.
Price to earnings ratio is a
good a quick way of comparing
two companies relative
to their growth or
relative to an industry.
But it does lose a lot of
information relative to how
the companies are capitalized.
You saw in the last video that
how you're capitalized, and
when I say capitalized
I mean how do you
pay for your assets.
If you have a lot of debt versus
a lot of equity, what
actually happens on
the earnings line
is very, very different.
And so you lose all of
that information.
And so if you want to capture
that information, when you
look at the price of a stock
you have to figure out what
you're actually paying for the
enterprise of the company, the
enterprise value
of the company.
So when I talk about the
enterprise, or the enterprise
value, I'm talking about
the operating assets.
It gets a little bit more
complicated if you're talking
about a financial company
like a bank or
an insurance company.
But if we're talking about a
widget factory, the enterprise
is essentially the assets.
The enterprise value is the
asset value of the assets that
allow the company
to do business.
So whatever factories-- well, in
this case it's a pizzeria,
so the ovens, the building,
the places, where people
actually eat their food, and
even the cash that's necessary
to operate the business.
The enterprise value shouldn't
incorporate the cash that's
surplus, that's not necessary
to operate the business.
So that begs the question,
how do you calculate the
enterprise value?
So you could go backwards and
you say, OK, for a given price
how much am I paying for
an enterprise value?
So let's say that this stock--
let's say that Company A or
this one, let's say the stock
right now is trading at $20.
So this is the current price
that you could buy it at.
So it's the asking price in
the market is at $20.
While this one is at, let's
say it's at $10.
It's at $10.
So at first glance you might
just do a quick price to
earnings ratio.
And you'll say, OK, for $20 I'm
getting $2.10 earnings per
year, assuming it's not
growing or something.
So my price to earnings is
approximately, I don't know
have my calculator in front of
me, but $20 divided by $2.10
is going to be 9 point
something, something.
Right?
While this guy, for $10,
I am getting $1.89 of
earnings per year.
So what's 100 divided by 18?
It's 5 or 6 times.
It's going to be 5
point something.
6 times 18 is 60 plus -- Yeah
it's going to be 5 point
something, something.
So when you superficially just
look at this you're going to
say, wow, this is a cheaper
price to earnings ratio, maybe
I should buy that.
But what we saw in the last
video is that price to
earnings isn't a good relative
valuation metric when two
different companies are
capitalized very differently.
So what you want to do is
instead back out what these
prices imply about the
enterprise value.
So what does $20 imply about the
enterprise value and what
does $10 imply.
And how do you do that?
Well first you say what
is the market cap?
Market cap.
So you take the price times
the number of shares.
If you remember, we
had 10,000 shares.
So in this case $20 times
10,000 shares implies a
$200,000 market cap.
In this case we have $10 times
10,000 shares so it implies a
$100,000 market cap.
Now remember, the market cap
is just what's left over.
So let me redraw those two
diagrams because I feel like
I'm--
So for this entrepreneur
you have the assets
and there's no debt.
So the assets are kind
of completely
represented by the equity.
So if the market cap is $200,000
you're essentially
saying that these assets, these
operating assets, are
worth $200,000.
So in this case, at a price
of $20, we know that the
enterprise value, the market
enterprise value, so what the
market is saying the enterprise
is worth, the
operating assets are
worth, is $200,000.
Now, in this case, remember the
market is saying that the
equity is worth $100,000.
Let me draw that.
The market is saying that the
equity is worth $100,000.
But of course this company
has a lot of debt.
It has another $100,000
of debt.
Actually let me draw this
a little bit different.
All right.
So in this situation the market
is saying that its
market cap is $100,000.
So just to be proportional
let me draw it like that.
Not really use that one.
So $100,000, this is the
equity or the market
capitalization or the market
value of the equity.
That's what the market cap is.
So that's just the price times
the number of shares.
And then it has debt.
If I remember correctly it
has $100,000 in debt.
We take $100,000 in debt.
$100,000.
And so what is it saying
about the assets?
So the equity plus
the debt, or the
liabilities, is $200,000.
So it's saying all of the assets
are worth $200,000.
This is all of the
assets, $200,000.
But what we need to do, we want
to figure out the value
of the enterprise.
Not just all of the assets.
So if we remember there was some
of the assets that were
actually operational and some
were non-operational.
So we had $10,000 of
cash right there.
So we have $10,000 of cash.
So when this stock is trading
at $10 it implies a market
capitalization of $100,000.
It implies that the liabilities
plus equity is $200,000.
So all of the assets
are $200,000.
But if we were to subtract out
the cash or the non-operating
assets, what's not necessary
to operate the business, we
get $190,000 of enterprise
value.
So in this case we're
saying that the
enterprise value is $190,000.
So in this case, when you look
at the price to earnings
you're like, wow, this is half
as expensive as that.
This is great deal,
let me buy it.
And I just happened to make up
the numbers so even when I did
the enterprise value it's
only 5% cheaper.
Here it looks 50% cheaper.
Here it looks 5% cheaper.
And so it might be a
little unintuitive.
To figure out the enterprise
value you take, and this will
be the formula you see
in a lot of books.
Enterprise value is equal
to market cap
plus debt minus cash.
And you might be like, when I'm
trying to value something
why should I add debt back?
Debt is a negative thing.
Shouldn't debt make my
enterprise worth less?
And why am I subtracting cash?
Because cash is a positive
thing, shouldn't that make my
enterprise value more?
And the reason why, first, you
subtract cash is, and it
really should be just cash that
is not associated with
the enterprise.
And you'll see a lot of people
do it in different ways.
Some people subtract out all
cash with the argument that
the company doesn't need
to use any of it.
But the real idea behind it is
to kind of capture the assets
that are actually generating the
profits of the enterprise.
And the profits of the
enterprise are
the operating profits.
And the reason why you
add debt is, think
about it this way.
If you wanted to buy
out this company.
Let's say from this company you
wanted to buy his assets
at the market price.
How would you do it?
You would have to pay, what?
You would have to maybe
get $200,000.
If you got $200,000 you could
buy these guys off.
You could pay them $100,000
and own that.
And then you could
buy the bank out
and pay them $100,000.
So if you paid $200,000, you
would own all of this.
Right?
This would all be your equity.
And then you would get $10,000
back if you know if you wanted
to take this cash, right?
So you would have essentially
paid $200,000 which is the
market cap plus the debt.
That's what you would have to
do to buy out both of those
stakeholders in the company.
And then you would get
back the cash.
So you would have to pay net
$190,000 to own this
enterprise.
And hopefully that makes a
little bit more sense as why
the enterprise value is actually
described this way.
Now the one thing you might say,
OK, Sal, you figured out
how to calculate enterprise
value from a share price.
But what if I want to go
the other way around.
How do I figure out what a
company's enterprise value
should be and then figure
out what its share
price should be?
Well one metric, and there's
two metrics.
The most common metric that's
used is EBITDA.
EBITDA.
I won't cover that now because
it's a new term for you, but
it means earnings before
interest, taxes, depreciation,
and amortization.
And people look at something
called an enterprise value to
EBITDA ratio.
And I'll do that in
the next video.
But what I like to do is just
think about, OK, what are the
real earnings from
the enterprise?
Well, that's the operating
profit.
That's the operating
profit, right?
And then you could apply a
multiple to that based on what
other companies are trading at
or how fast it's growing.
Let's say in this case we're
saying they're both generating
$30,000 in operating
profit per year.
Let's say that I want to
apply a 5 multiple to
its operating profits.
So let's say I want to say that
EV to operating profit,
which I frankly think is a
better metric than EV to
EBITDA-- and I'll cover EBITDA
in a future video-- let's say
that I think for this industry
it should be 5.
Let me say it should be 6.
6 times is a good multiple.
So in both those cases the
operating profit was $30,000.
So that means that EV should be
$30,000 times 6, which is
equal to $180,000.
Now for the first guy if the EV
is $180,000, if I'm saying
that this thing right here, the
market value, should be
$180,000, then I'm implying
that the equity should be
worth $180,000.
And there are 10,000 shares.
So essentially I would take that
EV and I would say, well,
all of that's equity, there's
no cash there, there's no
debt, so all of this
is equity.
So I would divide that
by the shares.
I would say that the market cap
for the first guy should
be $180,000.
So the per-share price,
the price I'd be
willing to pay, is $18.
Because it had 10,000 shares.
$18.
Now let's take the second
guy's situation.
We both agree in both situations
their enterprise
value should be $180,000.
But in this guy's case,
what are the assets?
The assets are the enterprise,
$180,000 plus $10,000.
Plus $10,000, right?
This whole left-hand
side is $190,000.
And then if you wanted to
subtract out, figure out the
market cap, you would take
this whole thing and then
subtract out the debt to
get the market cap.
Right?
And then you would be left with
this piece right here.
That right there, right?
You were just figuring out
this whole distance,
subtracting out this distance.
So essentially you would say
that the market cap is equal
to the enterprise value plus
the cash minus the debt.
And it's good to draw those
balance sheets if
you ever get confused.
Minus the debt.
So the market cap is equal to
$190,000 minus $100,000 is
equal to $90,000.
And so if you divide that by
10,000 shares you'd say that
I'm willing to pay
$9 per share.
So if you believe that the
enterprise value of these
pizzerias are identical and
that they're both worth
$180,000, you should
be willing to pay
$18 for Company A.
And if you're completely
equivalent to it, you should
pay $9 for Company B.
And now if you're a little bit
more aggressive you might like
the leverage, you might
like how Company B
is growing, et cetera.
Maybe you would like to pay a
premium for that leverage or
maybe you wouldn't, because it
also increases your risk.
Because you get leverage on the
upside or on the downside.
But anyways I wanted to
introduce you to value.
On the next video I'll introduce
you to EBITDA.